nearly 350 000 people in Clark County
have a hard time accessing and affording
nutritious food now a mobile Proteus
stand in downtown Las Vegas they're
trying to combat that issue 8 news now
reporter Brian will takes us to the
first pop-up of the season to explain
how it all works
awesome red pepper that is impressive in
any Market
Ginger Bernard Johnson has been living
in Las Vegas for more than 60 years he's
glad there's a place like this with
fresh fruits and vegetables it's local
we don't do a lot of local stuff anymore
like we used to and so I try to support
our town as much as possible and it's
always so much tastier all the food you
see here is locally grown and organic
providing better access to nutritious
food here in southern Nevada we know
that the Bonneville Transit Center gets
about 4 000 people boarding's on a
weekday so we know that if we bring it
here there are some people who out to
come and get fruits and vegetables there
will be a total of six of these pop-up
stands this year to help address the
broader issue of food insecurity the
program is funded thanks to a grant from
the Centers for Disease Control and
prevention anybody can buy their produce
from the stand all payment forms are
accepted even EBT and SNAP benefits
know that they should eat fruits and
vegetables but it's not always easy
right the cost is a barrier the
transportation is a barrier this is all
about removing barriers to people like
Johnson the produce and stuff looks
great I can't wait to get to the parking
lot
love a happy customer so the next pop-up
produce stand mark your calendar is
going to be Tuesday June 6th so as we
mentioned it'll be set up right there at
the Bonneville Transit Center which is
in the heart of downtown Las Vegas kind
of across from City Hall last year's
markets resulted in over 5200 pounds of
produce sold and about seven thousand
dollars in total sales with over 20
percent of sales from coming from snap
and EBT transactions